-Performing their hit,
"Just Wanna Rock,"
give it up for Lil Uzi Vert!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Ah, ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ I just wanna rock ♪
♪ Body-ody, yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ Damn ♪
-MC.
-Whoa!
♪ This ain't what you want ♪
-♪ Project, Project X ♪
-♪ This ain't what you want ♪
♪ This ain't what you want ♪
Ha!
♪ 1600 block,
I just wanna rock ♪
♪ I just wanna, ah, ah,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ I just wanna rock,
body-ody, yeah ♪
♪ Shawty got that body-ody,
ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ Hit her once, no ties ♪
♪ How the ... you gon'
kill my vibe? ♪
♪ Stand on my money,
don't know my size ♪
♪ Pick them sides, and you
better choose wisely ♪
♪ That's my high,
one, two, three, four ♪
♪ Throw up the five ♪
♪♪
♪ That's my high ♪
♪ Damn ♪
♪ Well, let's go ♪
♪ One, two, three, four,
throw up the five ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
♪ This ain't what you want ♪
-♪ Project, Project X ♪
-♪ This ain't what you want ♪
♪ This ain't what you want ♪
♪ Buh, buh, buh, buh ♪
-♪ Down, shake it down ♪
-♪ Buh, buh, buh, buh ♪
♪ Buh, buh, buh, buh ♪
♪ Buh, buh, buh, damn ♪
♪ Let's go ♪
-♪ Shake it-shake it down-down ♪
♪ Shake it down-down ♪
♪ Shake it-shake it down-down ♪
-♪ Whoa, let's go ♪
-♪ Shake it down-down ♪
♪ Shake it-shake it-shake ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]